I do not think people realize how the
United States would be in SpaceX did not
exist like we just killed the space
shuttle it's like Lockheed and Boeing
we're doing nothing new at all
um China has been pumping just billions
of dollars people would be freaking out
[Music]
all right guys bang bang I've got Ashley
here with me uh Ashley's got a brand new
book out when the heavens went on sale
The Misfits and Geniuses racing to put
space Within Reach I've read the entire
thing it's absolutely fantastic it is a
great space book follow-up to his book
on Elon Musk and I thought that'd be a
great place for us to start this
conversation is on Elon himself
obviously Elon is incredibly obsessed
with getting to Mars uh as you followed
him to write the original book and now
you've continued to kind of pay
attention to what SpaceX and Elon has
done what's changed is there changes to
the mission is there changes to Elon
personally what are you seeing as the
years go on
yeah you know the big mission is still
there he is obsessed with setting up
this human Colony on Mars
um he's always thought humans need a
backup plan uh you know spacex's
business itself has kind of changed in
some ways he always said you know it was
meant to be sort of build a business to
get to Mars and I guess that holds true
still but you know he used to say he's
not a moon person now SpaceX is doing
missions to the Moon
um starlink the space internet system is
like this massive part of the the
business that kind of just arrived in
the last
few years and that's really if you look
at spacex's valuation you know there's
there's almost like no money in actually
launching Rockets even when you do it
SpaceX style which is pretty cheap and
fast uh All the Monies in satellites
data communication so spacex's value is
like totally tied up in in starlink
um
so you know I think there's there's like
all this added complexity to in business
to the mission
um but at the same time
it's hard it's hard to like if you're if
you don't follow space super close and
it's like hard to convey how far ahead
this is like not space boy SpaceX Fanboy
talk you know this is just legit I mean
they're so far ahead of the commercial
space players but then all the nations
that have been doing this for decades
they're it it it's like it's kind of the
craziest business in the tech story I I
can fathom
um then you know beyond SpaceX yes Elon
has changed I'm more complicated and
it's sort of let himself lose I I get a
little sad I to me
um you know Twitter seems like a big
distraction he seems super worried about
AI I always kind of thought he would
slowly wind things down and just be
doing SpaceX all the time
when you look at
um SpaceX itself you mentioned just how
far ahead they are to me it's almost
like the operating system of space now
right is everyone's got to go through
SpaceX for the most part now in this
book you cover a bunch of startups that
want to change that they want to have
smaller Rockets or more you know kind of
uh takeoffs and kind of all these
different strategies but is it still
true that SpaceX really is you know the
big boy in the room and if you want to
go to space with a satellite or some
sort of cargo you're going on a SpaceX
rocket
yeah I mean to a large degree you know
like look Europe has Rockets Russia has
Rockets so that you know not many people
can use them now China India they can
all get you to space just not nearly as
frequently as SpaceX can and and usually
not as cheaply uh
your point is right I mean there's
dozens of Rocket companies so people
would kind of be like why I mean SpaceX
flies you know there's different classes
right there's got a large medium and
small rockets and SpaceX is pretty
dominant in the large part
um there's a huge thesis which I get
into in gory detail in the book that
look we're gonna put up we have about
like 9 000 satellites orbiting the earth
now that's been on an exponential
increase the last three years people
think we're gonna put up a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand pretty
quick
um you know not like nobody now produces
enough Rockets to make that happen so if
that becomes a reality and it looks
quite like it is going to then we need a
lot of Rocket players probably not not
dozens but but more but SpaceX would
still be the dominant player in that in
in that scenario um it's just that I
think there's probably more business to
go around the other thing is just I
guess Starship works it's such a
the rocket is so massive that
um you know SpaceX would be taking like
what we used to do for an entire year on
one launch into orbit at a lower cost
um there's a lot between here and making
that happen but that's you know anyway
things could get quite dramatic it'll be
interesting to see exactly how this all
plays out so I want to talk about uh the
companies that you cover in this book
and there were two things that I think
kind of came together that seemed to be
the drivers of this explosion of uh
space startups now SpaceX obviously
started you know more than 20 years ago
at this point and they've been at this a
long time but one of the things was this
guy Pete Warden who you cover you know
almost all throughout the entire book uh
talk a little bit about Pete his role at
Nasa this idea that like he kind of was
the misfit of NASA but he even has this
quote in the book where he's like you
know in times of War uh you need
different people who kind of think
outside the box than during times of
peace and and he was that guy uh-huh so
kind of talk talk about this guy maybe
his importance to this explosion of
startups going to space
yeah and he he gives one of the best
quotes I think he says something like in
times of War sometimes you need you know
great great glass for crazy and he was
kind of the great crazy General I mean
before Elon you know so Pete's Pete
Warren's a bit older he's probably close
to his 70s now
um he was he was like an astrophysicist
by training he had a PhD he ended up in
the air force became a general you know
hardly anybody knows about him but he's
like this figure that's been lurking
back it was like kind of a puppet master
all this time
um he worked on the Star Wars missile
defense Shield during the Reagan Era he
did a bunch of Black Ops stuff that he
can't talk about
um but yeah you know he ends up ends up
at NASA Ames which is like the Silicon
Valley NASA Center uh he's the director
there in kind of like the early 2000s
and
you know Pete for decades have been
writing papers like God the government
needs to get out of its own way we need
to make cheap Rockets we need to set
them up all the time we need to make
cheap satellites we have to piggyback on
Moore's Law and what's been happening in
consumer electronics but but NASA and
the military contractors were just sort
of you know allergic to any of these new
ideas but Pete the symbols like this
team of 20 somethings that NASA Ames
like his little dream team of space
weirdos to to go make some of these
ideas happen he had to like literally
kind of hide them in closets to keep
them away from senators and NASA
headquarters officials who were going to
shut down what they were doing but he
he kind of makes this
um New Era of commercial space happen a
lot of the startups in the book come
right out of NASA Ames and then Pete was
the one who gave SpaceX you know Elon
was funding SpaceX but when they they
wanted to fund their first mission uh
through the defense department Pete was
the one who really kind of made that
happen and so
um you know I see him in Elon is these
these two figures that that have
propelled all this forward so Pete
obviously was this huge driving uh
Factor you mentioned that he went and
found all like the space weirdos and
brought them together and what I took
away from the book is like when we talk
about weirdos we're not just talking
about like oh this person's not in NASA
we're talking about literally going and
finding like the 20 year old kid who uh
wants to blow [__] up right or like get
to space in some weird way
um it really was this like weird uh
collection of people
is that what it takes to kind of create
something brand new that's so disruptive
is like you have to go so much to The
Fringe of society and find these people
with these wild ideas and maybe the
naivety or the stupidity to like
actually go after them like talk a
little bit about that group that he had
put together there uh at that uh
facility
yeah I mean it's a great question uh you
know
there were a lot of people that he
brought in I call him Pete's kids but
there was there was kind of like this
special group that were particularly
close probably about a dozen people a
ton of them lived in a commune called
the rainbow mansion that I write about
in the book
um and yeah I think it's this
combination of
um you've got these young kids with all
these ideas and
they're capable but they've never
managed some huge budgets or had to put
like structure around a project and then
Pete was the he was like the wise and
old veteran in the room who could kind
of set that stuff up and then he could
also
it was really like the protection that
he gave them you know so he hands them
the resources and usually this
bureaucracy would come and just find its
way to to grind everything to a halt but
but Pete was that unique person who who
was yeah he almost got fired like 18
times I mean he was willing to like sort
of deal with a lot of crap
um and protect these people so I think
it's kind of this mix I think in space
um
I don't know if the average person
really realizes like how stuck in the
mud space had become and had just not
changed for like 30 40 years so yeah I
think you needed
like all these clean slates these these
people that had out there ideas it's
sort of like the kind of person that um
you know they're going to be told that
this is dumb like a thousand times and
they're still gonna do it so the other
kind of uh big Trend if you will was
this idea of taking consumer electronics
and being able to shoot them into space
and I didn't understand I think that
component of uh this explosion of space
startups uh where my understanding after
reading the book is uh basically there
was like space grade materials and there
were you know you'd spend 10 million
dollars on something that now is
available to Consumers literally for a
couple hundred bucks and there was a
period where people had the idea could
we take the consumer electronics and
would it survive going to space could it
be on a rocket Etc and so there's the
phonesat program and a bunch of this
stuff but talk maybe about that period
of time of like that kind of seems like
a stupid idea you know in hindsight of
like how simple it is but it does feel
like maybe that was a really really
pivotal moment for space uh kind of
exploration in general the Now consumer
electronics and the lower price points
could actually be used for this stuff
it really was in Planet labs you you
measure this fun side program they
literally said they like bought a Google
Nexus phone or a few of them and put
them on a rocket and launched them into
space to see if they would work and and
they did and that ended up being the
basis of Planet labs this company that
has all these Imaging satellites and and
I would argue SpaceX had this huge
effect on the the cost of rockets and
access to space but it was like that
moment where people finally got Moore's
Law and modern technology to space and
had this this Awakening um it's like
this weird historical baggage where
yeah space used to be really hard so you
wanted to make a super fancy radio that
you knew could survive the launch and
and all the harsh conditions of space
and then
time passed you know and you probably
didn't need that anymore but there was
some contractor in in like Alabama that
made the space grade radios and everyone
just bought them from them because they
always worked and so these were the
first people like I think
I think a cell phone might work up there
you know like Space is really freaking
cold the temperatures like swing a lot
the rocket launch itself is really
violent but it turned out these phones
work fine and so then
um everybody's Minds expanded at that
point and they're like oh you know
there's this there's been 40 Years of
turns of Moore's Law and all is Invasion
and now we can not only have cheaper
stuff in space but obviously it's going
to be more modern technology and and you
know just the last part of that is that
the thinking around satellites used to
be that you you spend a billion dollars
and you send this huge thing up and it
lasts for 20 years like you know after
20 years pass because it's not it's not
a super modern bit of equipment and so
like this was like a whole rethinking of
oh we should just make these satellites
last for like three or five years and
just swap them out all the time
so this brings me to uh Peter Beck and
uh you talk about like this rocket bike
which I think gets back to this idea of
kind of the space weirdoes right is the
same person who would put like a jet
engine on a bicycle and see how fast it
could go same person who thinks that
they can launch rockets into space
um but there's uh also a focus on like
doing it in New Zealand and not
necessarily doing it in the United
States uh you mentioned in the book
there was no infrastructure uh there was
no Aerospace industry there was no
anything in New Zealand and yet this guy
who literally was spending his time
putting you know rocket engines on
bicycles in his spare time decides he's
gonna go instead of horizontal he's
gonna go vertical uh it like how insane
is there a way to describe like how
crazy of an idea that was before it
actually came to fruition
you know I think it's like a one in
seven billion sort of situation
um I went to New Zealand a bunch of
times for this book I mean it's like
it's it's like as unique as SpaceX it's
just this weird or personal story in a
lot of ways um
Peter grew up in invercargill which I
don't know if anyone's ever had the
pleasure it's a very nice city but it's
like at the bottom of the south island
of New Zealand the next stop is
Antarctica it's like very rural there's
there's not much going on there and and
this is like not a kid who was you know
um
on his way to like a scholarship at MIT
or anything I mean he was very good with
his hands but he he didn't even go to
college he he was working in a
dishwasher maker an appliance maker as
like a apprentice and and like you said
so he used he was just obsessed with
rockets you know and Rocket he just
likes to go fast and so he has this he
has this house and he's got like a shed
out back and he's making like his own
propellants he used to put garbage bags
around his body to like protect himself
from the propellants and he made his own
rocket engines and he just got really
far
um
I forget how long ago it was like maybe
he made this rocket called the Atia one
and it was really just him and two
part-time people and and it it got to uh
to the edge of space
um as like basically a hobbyist project
and then turned that into a company and
man New Zealand has nothing I
interviewed the Prime Minister who was
who was running the country when Peter
was doing all this and he's like look
well first of all it was hilarious
because the Prime Minister showed up in
like a t-shirt and shorts and like
offered to pick me up in his car and
take me to brunch but uh he was like
look we've got we've got like two tanks
we barely have like a ship you know and
this guy's coming in telling me we're
going to space I was kind of like do we
want to you know get involved in that
that same sort of thing for us and
there's no talent to lean on nobody had
ever done this before and for people who
don't know rocket lab is like the second
coming of SpaceX I mean SpaceX
as long as hundreds of times rocket Labs
launched almost 40 and after that you
dropped down to like one or two very
quickly and and so I don't know man you
know
I do this for a living I sort of Chase
weirdos around the world and and I've
never met anyone like like Peter
what do you think makes them so
different is it just the upbringing is
it like literally growing up in New
Zealand you know literally uh kind of
changes the way you think is it
something about the family because I
know that there was a lot of mechanics
and and things that they were doing on a
day-to-day basis tinkering and unpacking
machines and things like that like what
what drove him to kind of end up in this
very different place
part of it has to be the genes because I
I sort of got super fascinated at his
dad who was like this expert in
everything he was like a master sculptor
he was like the world's leading
um Authority on Jade and like worked at
a museum he built his own telescope for
the museum
um that Peter used to sort of like help
out with as a kid and yeah so they just
had this garage Peter had two brothers
and they just sat there tinkering on
cars Non-Stop and it was just like uh it
was like this brotherly competition to
see who could who could do more but you
know Peter
is but come clear to me over time Peter
is some kind of Genius because
you know he built after that first
rocket they built this rocket held
electron which is their Workhorse today
is it's in its you can ask pretty much
anyone as far as small Rockets go it's
like the perfectly engineered rocket and
and yeah Peter had a team of hundreds of
people that helped him but there were
every countless times where it just
wasn't going to happen they couldn't
solve some problem and and I asked Peter
about this so that I was like yeah I
would just go take a shower you know and
like this idea would come to me of how
to fix this thing he
he seems to have some like intuitive
knowledge of life but he seems to be
able to translate some intuitive
knowledge of physics and the vision in
his head like very directly to his hands
if you ask anyone Pete's down there with
like a lathe and milling machine and
making the stuff himself so
um I don't know part of it's the culture
part of us is genes and then and then I
think he's just like exceptional he's
also not um
but he's possessed by having to make
stuff right like like he he made a
rocket engine just because like he he
had to he's not like Elon he's not
trying to make some Colony on Mars it
was more just like I want to see if I
can make a rocket engine and I'm like
and then uh I want to see if I can make
a rocket and then and then he just he's
just I think that's his calling is the
object itself yeah what's fascinating is
each person in the stories uh that you
tell in this book uh they seem to have
different drivers right and it goes back
to
um you know if you look at think of Elon
actually my wife has a a theory which I
don't think we'll ever get kind of
confirmation on but um when she read
your book she said listen you know it
seems like Elon was uh kind of a great
entrepreneur and he was going but when
his child passed away he became
possessed he wanted to save Humanity he
wanted to kind of go and and it became
this thing of like I'm going to level up
my ambition I'm going to level up you
know the risk that I'm willing to take
and that was like a very pivotal moment
did you find the same thing when when
you were actually spending time with him
and writing that book
yeah it's a hard thing to talk about you
know because elon's always you know his
first child died of sudden infant death
syndrome and um
elon's always kind of downplayed it you
know I mean maybe for obvious reasons he
just doesn't want to talk about it his
ex-wife though used to sort of try to
talk about it and you know I would just
say look what's the point of dwelling on
this I just gotta get to work
um
so you know it's a hard thing I did try
a few times to kind of get into it but
it was like one of those areas he just I
don't know he's
he lives in a bit more of like I would
call it like an expressive
state that when I was doing a lot of
interviews for the book I think some of
those things he wasn't used to talking
about
um but you know I don't know that's a
good question I never thought about it
fully like that he he like SpaceX had
already started
then but it was you know and he'd always
had this Mars idea in the back of his
head but at that point it was more like
to be in the southwest of space to be
really cheap and and um and more like
the people in the book to like get stuff
to space all the time really cheap
um
uh you have to imagine right that
something like that has a huge impact on
you and if there's like any defining
quality of Elon is like
this Relentless sort of pursuit of
making the most of your time that you
have and so so you know if you're
playing armchair psychologist you could
definitely see how that kind of would
feed into something like that yeah it's
fascinating to kind of think through you
know you've got uh Peter back you've got
Elon and kind of what's driving those
two guys but then you get to uh somebody
like Chris Kemp and for those that don't
know in in the book uh basically he has
a very similar drive and determination
and and it seems like kind of will his
way into doing things and there's this
uh now famous Alameda uh kind of uh
campus or site and uh it's abandoned and
he basically goes and he's trying to get
the Alameda city council and local
leaders to like essentially give it to
him right and be like hey like bring
industry here from the bay area right
like come and build this out and they're
kind of like waffling it seems and he
basically just moves in and just like
starts like fixing it up and on next
thing you know they're like well like I
guess we should just say yes because he
kind is like do doing what he said he
was going to do is that what actually
happened
yeah pretty much I mean so I was with
fast stress as like the first day they
started and man this place was like a
real shiple you know it was it was uh
like there's kind of two parts to it
there's two buildings that they've taken
over and one was this
it used to be a naval air base and so
during World War II this was like a
place where they um did a lot of repairs
to jet fighters and and the first
building Astra had was like this very
weird they used to test
jet engines inside so that so that like
our enemies couldn't see what was going
on or whatever and um and so they have
these huge like tunnels
um with like these 12 foot thick walls
and and these exhausts for all the fire
and but you know like this place was
full of uh
like softball league paperwork
typewriters that had been in City it was
like a city dub you know I was like all
the stuff the city had just been bearing
there for years there was like a dead
dude who got electrocuted trying to
um grab the Copper from some of the
wirings it was like a dead body in there
and uh you know the city didn't know
what to do with it part of it is like uh
they thought it was like a hazardous and
exactly like you said Chris was Chris is
like well I know what to do with this
you know and so so sometimes at night
they were just they would
bash down like in time they would have
to get stuff like a electric
um like a power subsystem into the
building and the door wasn't big enough
so they would like bash down an entire
like whoa the building put the electric
subsystem in in the middle of the night
when nobody could see the repair the
whole wall and uh and just keep moving
forward and and over time
this was a long process like like they
always got kicked out a few times you
know like the Fire Marshals would show
up and things like that but yeah over
time then the city walked in one day and
they have like this glorious rocket
Factory in the middle of Alameda which
is a very like
um Suburban City near Oakland so um yeah
Chris I think had had some of that Elon
Spirit similar things happened in the
early SpaceX days as well now the other
character that I want to talk about is
uh Max Max
how do you say his last name
all right so he's fascinating obviously
I think you call out in the book
multiple times like I've never been
around a person like this before uh for
those who are unfamiliar with him he
basically made a ton of money unclear
how much uh in uh building internet
companies in Europe he's Ukrainian
um again I say unclear because it's
unclear how much money you made it seems
like it's unclear in terms of all of the
different ways that he made the money in
some ways people are like look he's got
dating websites and things that you know
might not be for everyone but it's
understandable and there's plenty of
them here in the US and then there's
some people who accuse him of doing you
know maybe illegal things or close to it
uh potentially immoral things whatever
but he ends up with a ton of money
he then uh starts to invest heavily in
the space business and basically it
sounds like the U.S kind of railroaded
them right they basically said look man
you've got this business you've done all
this work you've invested all this
capital and right when the Rocket's
sitting on the launch pad and pretty
much ready to go they come to him and
say yeah we ain't letting a Ukrainian uh
benefit uh based on U.S space technology
is that kind of your take
pretty much one of the craziest stories
I've ever seen you know um you got
everything about Max right even weirder
he used to be like a ob gyn before he
was the software magnate you know his
parents
um work Ukraine was like the backbone of
the Soviet space program his parents
worked on the Soviet rockets and
software so it was kind of like it is
blood he ends up buying this this
bankrupt rocket maker in Texas called
Firefly and and Max had this crazy
Vision to try to unite like the old
Ukrainian Soviet space with like new
American space and
um yeah it was all going well for a
while he put 250 million dollars in a
firefly which after
that might actually be more than Elon
personally has put into SpaceX and is a
bit behind Jeff Bezos but after that you
know Max is kind of is right there and
took years the Firefly rocket is kind of
one of those medium sized Rockets like
it's no no joke it took a lot of money
and engineering and
and they got it to the pad at Vandenberg
in Southern California where a lot of
rockets Lodge from and then things
started to take a turn all of a sudden I
mean Ukraine is is obviously meant to be
like an ally of the U.S but the U.S
government started to have questions
about uh the Ukrainian owning a rocket
company that could fly from the United
States so they start like blocking him
they start messing with his other
businesses kind of like stopping the
transfer of money
um driven some things and then so I
obtained all these secret Dockers you
know siphius is the agency that like
raises these foreign ownership concerns
and I actually got the siphius
complaints against Max
um
I found it pretty like hilarious and
unsatisfying there's there's maybe like
two sentences about his Shady business
stuff and then there's like multiple
paragraphs that they essentially say
like
Ukraine is near Russia Russia is a space
superpower
um
Max is Ukrainian he may become a Russian
asset and like some point in the future
so we do not want him to own this
company I was like these things happen
I've covered like Huawei a lot you know
getting messed with by the US government
because of its Chinese ownership and
stuff I
unless the government has some amazing
confidential information I've never seen
anything like this to put like 250
million they let him it wasn't like this
went on for years nobody was questioning
it while he was pouring money into it it
was only once the rocket was ready and
they're like oh this was a bad idea you
know and um we could get into it a
little more if you want but but the
timing on this was terrible because they
sort of kick him out and then the
Ukraine war kicks off like a year later
when it would be pretty handy to have uh
someone like Max on your side well
what's fascinating to me is Elon
obviously is South African right you've
got Bezos who's an American but we just
talked about we've got people who are
from New Zealand we've got people from
kind of all these different uh countries
and not only are we talking about the
individuals themselves and kind of their
nationalities but also we're talking
about well family members or you know uh
grandparents and and you know it's it's
the classic like America is just the
home of immigrants and so
um you know it is in one way a kind of a
sad story right that somebody came to
the United States they poured all this
money into it they built out this
amazing thing on the other hand I guess
the question is like are there valid
concerns about non-americans owning
technology that is being developed in
the U.S specifically around space like
what what is your you're the foremost
expert that I would know uh on space at
this point in terms of all these
different companies all the nuances like
how do you balance it in your head in
terms of like maybe where the line
should be drawn uh versus where it is
today
so I got complicated thoughts on that
you know like in the in the max
situation in particular
um I thought it was a little ridiculous
because because Ukraine is an ally of
the United States like it would behoove
us to have
their Engineers
um
to set up this linkage between Ukraine
and the US you know there's been rumors
for like decades that that there's not
much money anymore in the Ukrainian
Space Program they have very smart
Engineers that those guys sometimes are
working for like North Korea or Iran on
on their icbms and stuff like that I
thought here's this guy who actually has
like a plan and he's like a man of
action and means and he's making this
happen
um like the bigger question
so
over the last couple of years we've seen
the US government throw out a couple
people like Max there's also a Russian
dude who had a space company and he got
tossed as well and there's always been
these concerns right because they are
like the Rockets are like icbms
um even rocket lab Peter Beck in New
Zealand
he's basically have to bag the United
States government to exist uh because
they did not want another country having
like an ICBM and even though New
Zealand's part of the the five eyes it's
like our closest Alliance um he has to
spend like a year going to see Obama to
to allow rocket lab to happen they have
to set up a headquarters in Los Angeles
it was sort of like a fake headquarters
for a while and and it's real now
um but
it's super complicated I think to me I
understand the roots of all this I think
it's like uh it's getting to be sort of
a archaic proposition
um
we used to not want our Aerospace
secrets to fall into other people's
hands like Peter Beck went on the
internet and read a few textbooks and
made the second most successful rocket
company in the world from New Zealand
with like no U.S help so my general
theory is that like
if you know just about anyone can do
this if they really put their mind to it
and are smart enough at this point and
then
you know I make a television show called
hello world where I go all around the
world interview scientists I just went
to like Kyrgyzstan and they have a team
of 10 women who are just College
undergrads who are making the country's
first satellite for like 250 000
um I don't know I just think it's like a
new era and
like if we're trying to keep
um
if our goal really is to like try to
keep
ICBM type technology out of the hands of
some Nations I just think it's sort of
pointless you know at this juncture it's
just it's like not gonna happen and and
the US doesn't
you know anyway yeah in China's doing
just fine with their space program I
just I I think it's uh I think these are
very like cold war Cold War kind of
Vibes that are still hanging around now
one of the parts of the book that um I
think I knew this existed but I didn't
understand the extent to which it
existed is uh there's a difference
obviously between the rocket company and
the launch pads and there's a payment
that gets made to the launch pad when uh
it is used but there's also payment that
gets made when it is supposed to be used
it's kind of reserved but not used it's
just a lower fee right kind of like hey
you wasted our time so give us some
money
um but in the book you talk about pretty
much people going around the world
they're going to Hawaii they're going to
various Islands they're going to Alaska
and I forget who it is but somebody goes
to India right and they're essentially
looking for uh these launch pads and
some of them it seems like have to do
with geography and kind of you know a
trajectory and things like that some
have to do with costs some of them have
to do with backlog of uh actual schedule
and things like uh that is there an
argument that the United States should
just go like create a bunch more launch
pads around the coastlines of the US and
like let's just go all in on space and
try to you know beat all these other
countries or is there actual value
either for the United States or for
these companies in having launch pads
literally be you know across geographies
across time zones across uh countries
and and that's actually a better thing
dude I'm impressed you're the first
person that is like picked up on all
this and they're like sort of
sophistication and and intricacies of
all these these pads and everything yeah
you know um I never thought about it
fully like that before the US is in some
ways
Launchpad Rich we've got stuff in
California Virginia Florida and Alaska
on the other hand most of those are
quite government or NASA controlled so
rocket lab
has the private Spaceport
um SpaceX has its one in Texas you know
which is is pretty Starship focused but
other than that you know it's hard to
find a private
um space board I think
the the US is disadvantaged to build a
ton more in that I think people are
going to be super worried about having
like uh you kind of need it as close to
the equator as you could get so you want
to be like Southern California Southern
Florida Alaska is good just like you
mentioned there's specific orbits you
can get to from up there
um but I think the trend on all this
really just today we saw this like old
concept coming back today which is is
these barges out at Sea I think a lot of
this moves to like offshore which is
getting totally away from people you
pump out a rocket in a factory you put
on a boat you send it to this uh this
barge and then launch it out in the
ocean and and obviously the U.S would be
in great shape to do something like that
and that was you know we talked about
Astra
um this company Alameda I mean this is
something they've been pursuing for a
long time so they're right by the water
it's just you literally
pop the rocket out of the factory out of
those boats and then like off it goes
maybe even the the same day or the next
day
um I think that's probably where we're
heading it's like less less
infrastructure instead of more when you
think about those barges are these like
normal barges that could just be
converted or do you think they have to
be kind of custom built obviously I
think a lot of people uh will think of a
barge in space and they'll see you know
the rocket boosters come and re-land on
these like drone ships in the ocean with
SpaceX is that what we're talking about
like SpaceX is the only one that can
land this is more this is more on the
Disposable end and yeah they have to be
like you have to have some
infrastructure but this is also like we
whatever picture most of us had this
picture in our head of like 120 people
in this like massive mission control and
everybody's got a job and they've all
got the red phone and they're sweating
you know like Astro watches their
Rockets with like two people in a
modified you know trailer uh shipping
container that can go anywhere around
the world this is really where we're
heading so the barges have to have like
some infrastructure to fuel the rockets
and stand it up and all that stuff but
otherwise no man it's just a just like a
flat flat all you need is a little flat
surface and stand the thing up and shoot
it yeah it's absolutely incredible to
kind of think about how quickly this is
all uh all playing out
um I want to talk about uh companies
like varda as well as you know uh I'm an
investor in it but what's interesting to
me is in reading the book uh now I feel
much more educated to talk to Delhi and
will and those guys right and be a
little dangerous feel better about your
investment man yeah sure for sure but if
I had to segment out the industry you
know kind of after reading the book it's
like okay you have to launch pads you
also have a lot more of the kind of
public stuff
um then you've got all these rocket
companies and that's really where the
focus has been right is how do we get
these rocket companies I think SpaceX
was starlink they're the first ones or
one of the first ones but okay like now
that we can get to space what do we do
when we're there right we've got
obviously a couple of other companies
that are trying to do things around
satellites and stuff like that varda is
trying to do manufacturing or these like
space Factory type things
um talk about maybe not just Florida but
like what is the cohort of companies
that are going to say all right I don't
want to worry about the rocket thing
like I'll just hitch a ride with these
folks who already figured out the rocket
thing but I want to focus on what we
actually do once we get to space I've
seen I think Bezos and blue origin talk
some of this as well like what are you
seeing there that's interesting to you
or or what are some of the companies or
people that I think people should pay
attention to
yeah I mean
honestly the Rockets are sexy and fun to
watch but this is like where most of the
action is and I think the money and and
there's just tons more companies than
rocket companies
um just super quick you know this
like we would not be having this
conversation five years ago I mean this
stuff is like flipped so quick and and
part of it is like the industry has
matured so you used to be a rocket maker
and now and that was all you did and now
companies like rocket lab so they make
the rocket and then they make 90 of what
goes into a satellite the electronics
the solar panels if you're a another
startup you just take your fancy camera
or your scientific experiment and you
just plop that into rocket Labs little
certain sort of bust I mean this is what
varda is doing in fact and
um you know this just saves a ton of
cost it used to be like every startup
used to have to do all this work
basically building the innards of the
satellite for just
trying to do their mission in space
um like in the book I argue
we've Communications and imaging have
been these first two major businesses
and we do have thousands upon thousands
of satellites through that we're gonna
add more I think varda represents like
that so I think they're going up what
next month I think in June yep I think
it's June yeah so and on that rocket I
mean I think that rocket is like a
symbol of a moment in time because
it is our first one where we're really
getting to new new businesses like
everyone's always said oh there's
Imaging and Communications and a little
sort of fringe science for Laboratories
but like what is the next business so
Bart is going to go up they're going to
make Pharmaceuticals you know
um there's Astro Forge
I used to think asteroid mining was
insane until I actually went to astral
forge's office
um for my show and and it looks it's a
very talented team it looks very real to
me they're setting up their first
they're not like mining an asteroid
right away but they're setting up their
first you know like prototype to see if
they can
um burn through a sample up there and
get some data off of it and so pretty
quickly like
we are now I would broadly call it
manufacturing of different Stripes you
know and I think I think we're going to
move industry
um into low earth orbit there's a lot of
sense of putting things like data
centers that can be solar powered up
there
um all kinds of interesting things you
can do with molecules
um in without gravity pressing on you so
I think I think we're like right at this
very moment this whole thing is kicking
off in in a new way it reminds me like
I'm old enough to sort of live through
like the 1996 consumer internet where we
we laid all this fiber and we're
building these data centers and
everyone's like talking about killer
apps all the time is annoying but you
know everyone's searching for like
whatever we know there's something here
like what are people gonna do
some of the business models were maybe
obvious but nobody would have guessed
like sort of what 2023 fully looks like
and and we're running this huge
experiment and low earth orbit is like
are we having that same moment right now
and do these things check out or do they
not
I gotta ask a couple of questions that
I've always been obsessed with one
are we gonna colonize Mars in our
lifetime
you know
people
I am I could I could not be more
convinced the SpaceX is going to send
Rockets to Mars it's gonna send tons of
stuff to Mars
when you get to like an actual human I
get uh it is awful right it's like a
six-month ride
you really want to believe that you get
a ride back
you got to put up we've got to put up
some sort of infrastructure
um to uh
some sort of infrastructure to like let
a human inhabit that I would say when I
finished the book on Elon in like 2015 I
was
pretty convinced that of sort of what
SpaceX would do there I'm more convinced
than ever that that company is like the
most capable
um company the most capable like
Arrangements of thousands of people
maybe that's like ever been assembled so
um I don't know if I'm ready to commit
to full colonization I am
super confident we're going to send
stuff to Mars and and I think probably
like we have some people try it out you
know I I
I'm less optimistic than Elon about like
how hospitable it ends up being up there
do you think Elon dies
on Earth or on Mars
it's always said he wants to die on Mars
man
um I think if you asked him these days
he'd probably tell you like an AI was
gonna assassinate it
I'm kind of surprised he hasn't been on
one of these SpaceX missions now you
know we just set up another batch of uh
of like private astronauts no come on
keep that man on Earth protect him at
all costs do not let him get on any
Rockets
they're pretty safe man it's probably
safer than being in a car I understand
but still in the one-off chance can you
imagine the damage that would be done to
the space industry that Elon Musk
something happened to him on a rocket
you know it's and again I'm sorry I'm
this is really not meant to like be a
fan boy certain things SpaceX is just
very cool I do not think people realize
how [__] the United States would be in
SpaceX did not exist like
we just killed the space shuttle
it's like Lockheed and Boeing we're
doing nothing new at all
um China has been pumping just billions
of dollars people would be freaking out
I I laugh sometimes
um I mean look Elon brings a lot of
a lot of grief upon himself and says
some crazy things I I always I laughed
that uh
it's so black and white and like I find
the whole conversation sort of stupid
sometimes it's like it's like okay
on some level why do you care what
anybody says just look at the last 20
years of what this person actually did I
mean it sort of speaks for itself it's
also crazy to do it in 20 years is that
like look at uh blue origin you know
um they've done okay I mean they have
like these tourist lights they've
existed for just as long as SpaceX
um nowhere in the same ballpark you
think like the Billionaire's got like a
group chat and they're just like yo I'm
starting a space company the next one's
like me too
dude if they do Eli's crap it all over
him because like Bezos and Branson have
had a tough time of it before Paul Allen
passed away it really hasn't gone that
well for them I when does this podcast
go up uh this week
this week I mean later this week I got a
story running on uh an exclusive story
on Sergey Brin who is not doing Rockets
but you will see he's also getting in
the Aerospace game
um there does there seems to be a thing
right it's like I guess after you've
bought uh
a mega yacht you have to like of course
move on buddy but elon's the only one
who's turned it into a real business you
know
um I think I used to not be a moon
person I was sort of like yeah let's
just do the Mars Stadium the Moon is is
actually getting interesting now we got
like a couple
you know private companies working with
NASA to send humans back but then
there's companies now that are like
starting to think about private colonies
on the moon which is actually affordable
now they're putting private satellites
around the Moon I actually I think the
moon gets pretty interesting in the next
10 years
couple more questions for you uh we now
are getting to a point where we've got
like air traffic control of all these
satellites and how do we actually keep
them from colliding with each other we
then get into like the whole like
military industrial complex and like you
know can I shoot down your satellite can
you shoot down mine you mentioned in the
book that Russia basically took out one
of their own satellites as kind of a
reminder like yo we have missiles that
can that can hit these things
um is there legitimacy and like uh
offensive or just defensive capabilities
when it comes to this space force thing
is there going to be like a black water
kind of you know private uh you know uh
Defense Force that you can hire to
protect your satellites like what's
going on in in kind of the military
components of this both with the the
military space force but also uh with
maybe private companies trying to get
into that game
man that is a cool I'm going to write a
short story
after this I mean I don't think people
realize how weird [__] is about to get
um like Andrew absolutely needs space
defense service that that would be cool
I could see this I could see this you
know it's like on on the big level right
everybody should be incented to not
screw this up because the second you
blow somebody else's satellite up you
kind of just risk taking out your own
service so you like on one level people
should be rational actors I think Russia
has already
you know Russia is the great wild card
at all this giant space super power with
Space Program collapsing
um no commercial space startups at all
to speak of like how do they sort of
handle this new world China's like this
mix of government like trying to sort of
become private and then the US is just
like roaring commercial space the like
government guys are kind of laggards
um I don't know how things are going to
go there's other stories in the book too
like people should know you know I think
as China put up a satellite that then
popped out a baby satellite that would
like just hang out by American
satellites and and it didn't seem to be
doing anything but it was sort of like
uh if we wanted to shove you out of
orbit we probably could or maybe we
could pack you so it's really strange in
the defense department my God yes they
desire the ability to like
fly a rocket
tomorrow to put a satellite right over
whatever they want and and they're
getting like close to that
we did it's an asteroid right didn't we
didn't we send a rocket and like hit an
asteroid and try to uh redirect the
asteroid
yeah we've done stuff like that but and
this is this is like Utah yeah they call
it responsive space I mean the dod has
been fantasized this is like space force
all comes from this and Pete Warden who
we talked about is like kind of the
progenitor of a lot of this it's it's
just treating
space like another arm of the military
where like something breaks out you
mobilize your air your aircraft carriers
your your jets your troops and then you
start sending Rockets up to do stuff you
know um the problem is like
there's things we really depend on like
GPS today which is you sort of take it
for granted but it's like this glue that
makes your cell phone work and and all
kinds of Transportation work I mean the
second we screw something up in space
that dot you know like we can we can
back in time quick quickly all right
last question for you are aliens real
this is funny man okay so Pete Warden
you know
astrophysicist Black Ops
if somebody should know about aliens is
him I've spent a lot of time with Pete
have asked them this several times I
mean he's actually like look for foreign
too I'm like look man
you're going up there more than anybody
else
if aliens were gonna contact someone
it's probably you you know Eli says he's
got nothing either so I don't know do
they do they believe that they exist or
do they just believe hey we haven't come
in contact with them yet
like I think I Elon I I sort of get the
feeling he doesn't even think about this
much Pete's
um you know he wants to explore the
outer reaches of the solar system and
he's he's being funded by Yuri Milner
right now to make like a a probe that
would go out of our soul like Pete wants
to find I think he believes that he
wants to find find stuff
um so you know it's one of the greatest
it's one of the greatest conquests that
a human could do right now like the
person yeah the person who contacts
aliens
you know Thomas Edison uh you know
Nikola Tesla you go through all these
things all these inventions all these
things like there's certain people in
history I think Elon for uh SpaceX and
kind of reasonable uh Rockets all stuff
like he'll be remembered for literally
centuries the person who contacts aliens
first they're on the map I saw I saw
Andy Weir who wrote The Martian he
tweeted yesterday he's like you realize
there's a non-zero chance that our first
contact with aliens will be a dick
pickup
but you know I don't know man if
um I wish I knew this is I Elon will pay
the aliens off in Dogecoin just for the
last
can you imagine if uh Alien if Elon was
her first Contact I don't know I don't
know for us he would be attacked no one
would believe him he'd be just attack
they'd be like shut up you don't know
anything you're stupid
I think you're probably right all right
Ashley this book was fantastic when the
heavens went on sale The Misfits and
Geniuses racing to put space Within
Reach uh what I love about it is you
kind of build off of the work that you
did in uh the book on Elon but also you
cover uh what now have become some of
the most important companies in space
you've got a bunch of people in here uh
people who worked at Nasa people who are
building these companies uh but also you
you help explain I think some of the
difficulties and complexities in doing
this stuff right it's not just like hey
raise somebody from venture capital is
go out onto this launch pad launch the
thing into space we all get rich there
is a ton of complexity uh and one of the
things that you know I think people
probably don't understand is uh when you
build the first rocket it's not supposed
to actually make it to space right like
if you if you launch a rocket and it
goes to space the first time like you
are the one in a billion right it's
actually no we're just launching it yeah
yeah you may be the only one and so I
think the book is just does a great job
one explaining uh kind of the frontiers
of space and why people are doing this
but also the progress we've made to date
so far so I highly suggest people go get
it again when the heavens uh went on
sale The Misfits and Geniuses racing to
put space Within Reach it's even got the
really great photo on the front so if
you're watching this uh it's worth it I
promise
um any last words from you Ashley where
can we send people to find you uh online
yeah man the uh we're gonna make a HBO
documentary about that here we're in the
process
um I spelled my name a little weird with
two e's just ashleyvance.com or at
Twitter same thing
um and I uh it was great being on with
you Pop I appreciate it man I appreciate
you taking the time a couple years out
of your life to write the book and then
let me read it in a few hours
we will definitely do this again in the
future and I appreciate it
all right thanks man